la última vez vimos que para un tubo
abierto o una tubería con ambos extremos
abiertos sólo hay ciertas longitudes de
onda particulares que se permiten ahí
pues debemos tener anti nodos en ambos
extremos
tenemos este tenemos ese y tenemos este
otro encontramos la longitud de onda de
cada una de estas y nos dimos cuenta de
que podíamos encontrar una fórmula para
expresar las todas cualquier longitud de
onda posible en un tubo con ambos
extremos abiertos esto depende solamente
de la longitud del tubo que llamamos l y
también depende de n n se refiere a cuál
armónica queremos 1 es la fundamental 2
es la segunda armónica 3 es la tercera
armónica y así sucesivamente esto nos da
todas las posibles longitudes de onda
para este caso
ahora la pregunta es podremos hacer lo
mismo para el caso en el que uno de los
extremos está cerrado
qué pasaría si cerráramos por ejemplo
este extremo pues vamos a hacerlo aquí
tenemos un tubo que tiene un extremo
cerrado parece más una lata de refresco
ya que la parte de arriba estará abierta
que es por donde tomamos el refresco y
la parte de abajo estará cerrada para
que no se salga el refresco tenemos aire
adentro y si soplamos que posibles
frecuencias podremos generar que es lo
que sabemos bueno sabemos que este
extremo está abierto por lo que esta
molécula de aire puede oscilar
libremente qué tipo de nodo es este pues
va a ser un anti nodo ya que puede
oscilar mucho pero en las moléculas de
este lado pues van a continuar golpeando
con la tapa del fondo no se van a poder
mover mucho por lo que en este extremo
tendremos un nodo ya que no puede darse
el desplazamiento de las moléculas
entonces aquí tenemos un nodo este punto
lo ponemos justo en el eje ya que no
tiene ningún desplazamiento y nuevamente
estoy graficando el desplazamiento en
este caso el desplazamiento horizontal
aquí sabemos que hay un anti nodo y voy
a dibujar la onda más simple posible que
va desde este anti nodo hasta este nodo
luce así que parte de una longitud de
onda es esto bueno con base en la
longitud de este tubo si esto es el que
longitud de onda es está en términos de
l
el truco aquí es ver qué tanto de una
longitud de onda es esto y esto es algo
que molesta a muchos estudiantes porque
no les gusta encontrar qué es esto pero
realmente no es difícil de encontrar a
mí me gusta dibujar primero como luce
una longitud de onda completa comenzamos
aquí y una longitud de onda va a
recorrer todo esto hasta llegar al mismo
punto en el proceso
esta es una longitud de onda completa al
menos en una gráfica con respecto a x
que parte de una longitud de onda será
esta onda púrpura de nuestra longitud de
onda fundamental bueno comienza desde
aquí arriba
baja hasta tocar al eje es decir hasta
llegar al nodo y eso es todo y esto es
una cuarta parte de una longitud de onda
esto hasta aquí es una cuarta parte
luego de aquí acá es otra cuarta parte y
de aquí a acá es otra cuarta parte
esto es una cuarta parte de una onda y
esto es difícil de distinguir para
algunas personas todo esto es una
longitud de onda la mitad de esto es
media longitud de onda y si corto esta
mitad a la mitad tendré una cuarta parte
así que lo que encontré es que l es
igual a una cuarta parte de una longitud
de onda
nuestra longitud de onda fundamental
dividida entre 4 es igual a la longitud
de este tubo lo que quiere decir que mi
longitud de onda fundamental para este
caso es igual a 4 por l lambda es igual
a 4 por l y esta es mi longitud de onda
fundamental al menos para este caso del
tubo con un extremo cerrado y esto es
más grande en el caso de los dos
extremos abiertos
esto era 2 l encontramos la siguiente
armónica en el caso anterior no
tendríamos ningún modo en el medio así
que ahora voy a buscar tener un nodo a
la mitad
voy por aquí tengo
en el medio y ahora subo hasta llegar al
otro nodo que se encuentra al final
tengo un nodo aquí y un nodo al final
tengo mi anti nodo aquí y cuánto de una
longitud de onda es esto
vamos a calcularlo comencemos arriba
pasamos por el eje llegamos hasta abajo
y volvemos a subir hasta el eje esto es
lo que tenemos de una longitud de onda
tenemos un cuarto dos cuartos tres
cuartos así que ahora l que es la
longitud de mi tubo es igual a tres por
la longitud de onda entre cuatro
si despejo mi longitud de onda me va a
quedar que esto es igual a 4 l entre 3
así que la siguiente longitud de onda
posible es 4 l entre 3 y la siguiente
onda posible va a comenzar con un anti
nodo aquí y tiene que terminar con un
nodo acá y como la anterior tuvo un nodo
intermedio este deberá tener dos nodos
intermedios comienza aquí llega un nodo
va por abajo sube llega a otro nodo
sigue subiendo y ahora baja hasta el
nodo final siempre debemos tener un nodo
al final ya que no se está moviendo y en
este caso tenemos dos nodos intermedios
cuanto de una longitud
será esto vamos a dibujarla comenzamos
aquí arriba vamos bajando tocamos el
primer nodo seguimos bajando llegamos al
fondo vamos subiendo llegamos al segundo
nodo seguimos subiendo hasta arriba esto
no se acaba aquí tengo que continuar
otra cuarta parte de la longitud de onda
esto es más que una longitud de onda así
que ahora él le va a ser igual bueno de
aquí hasta acá tengo una longitud de
onda completa y a esto le agregó una
cuarta parte de longitud de onda una
longitud de onda y un cuarto o lo que es
lo mismo cinco longitudes de onda entre
cuatro
o lo que es lo mismo cinco cuartos de
longitud de onda ya que justo hasta acá
tenemos una longitud de onda completa y
a esto le agregamos una cuarta parte más
si despejamos lambda va a ser igual a
cuatro l entre 5 y ahora estoy
observando un patrón nuestra siguiente
longitud de onda posible es 4 l entre 5
y ahora con lo que hemos visto podemos
hacer una generalización de cualquier
longitud de onda posible para este caso
mi longitud de onda n va a ser igual
bueno vemos que en todos los casos
tenemos 4 l 4 l entre 3 4 l entre 5 y el
siguiente va a ser 4 l entre 7 así que
las longitudes de onda posibles para un
tubo que tiene un extremo cerrado va a
ser 4 por l / / m
excepto que n en lugar de ser cualquier
número entero posible
los únicos enteros posibles van a ser
los impares así que no puedo usar ni el
ni el 4 ni ningún número par solo los
impares 13 5 etcétera y esa es la
fórmula para conocer cualquier longitud
de onda posible en un tubo que tiene un
extremo abierto y otro cerrado depende
de la longitud y depende de n y se
parece un poco a la del caso con los dos
extremos abiertos excepto que en ese
caso era 2 l y aquí tenemos 4 l y aquí
abajo solo es posible usar los números
impares por lo que sólo tendremos
armónicas impares no va a ser la segunda
armónica será la tercera armónica y está
del 5 acá no va a ser la tercera
armónica va a ser la quinta armónica
aquí perdemos todas las armónicas pares
para el caso en el que tenemos un
extremo cerrado es algo extraño pero es
lo que sucede cuando tenemos un anti
nodo en este extremo y un nodo en este
otro ésta es una función de l
si quieren probar esto la siguiente vez
que estén tomando un refresco
él es grande si la longitud de su bote
es grande significa que la longitud de
onda también va a ser grande y si la
longitud de onda es grande bueno vemos
que b es igual a lambda por efe y si
tenemos una longitud de onda grande
quiere decir que vamos a tener una
frecuencia pequeña y esto es porque la
velocidad no cambia la velocidad está
determinada por el medio y es muy
probable que no estén cambiando la
temperatura del medio que está en su
bote quizás tengan su refresco helado y
cuando pase el tiempo ya no va a estar
tan frío pero no es un gran cambio de
temperatura por lo que la velocidad
tampoco va a cambiar si incrementamos la
longitud vamos a incrementar la longitud
de onda y vamos a decrementar la
frecuencia y una frecuencia baja quiere
decir una nota baja es decir vamos a
escuchar una nota más grave así que
intenten calcular esto la próxima vez
que estén bebiendo un refresco
cuando estén tomando una bebida
saludable van a tener su bebida aquí
hasta cierto nivel el nivel en donde se
encuentre el líquido va a hacer como el
fondo del bote por lo que mi tubo va a
tener esta longitud la parte de arriba
está abierta y el fondo es donde se
encuentra el nivel de este líquido
cualquiera que éste sea ya que el aire
no puede pasar más allá de este nivel de
líquido
sigan soplando por arriba y cuando lo
hagan tratan de distinguir qué nota
escuchan y si siguen haciendo esto van a
estar escuchando notas cada vez más
bajas mientras más bajo sea el nivel del
líquido
tendremos que la longitud de nuestro
tubo es mayor al soplar vamos a escuchar
una nota más grave y si el líquido está
ya casi al fondo del bote
tendremos una longitud aún más grande y
escucharemos una nota aún más grave no
va a tener mayor volumen sino que va a
escucharse más grave la frecuencia va a
ser más baja mientras más llevamos
tendremos menos líquido
la longitud va a aumentar y nuestra
frecuencia va a disminuir